hey everyone i'm shambly and i welcome
you all to this new video simply learn
on dogecoin wallet we covered what
dogecoin is
its value today and understood dogecoin
mining and its concepts
in the previous two videos now let's
proceed further
and look at how to create a dojo point
wallet and how to use it
but before moving any further let's see
what we have for you
in this video first we will have a quick
introduction to what is dogecoin
followed by how to buy dogecoin then we
will understand what a dogecoin wallet
is
and what are the types of those coin
wallet
then we will look into how to create a
dojo wallet
and how to use it after that
we will figure out why dogecoin is so
popular
and finally we will go through the top
five dodge coin wallets in 2021
so without wasting any time let's get
started what
is torch point dogecoin is a
peer-to-peer
open source cryptocurrency that works on
a blockchain technology
also it provides its users a completely
unknown
decentralized and secure environment
free from any third-party interference
to make their transactions
torch coin uses cryptography to secure
all its transactions
now let's proceed further and have a
look at the process
of how to buy dogecoin you can buy
dogecoin by following
these steps step one create a dot coin
wallet
step 2 locate your specific dogecoin
address
which is a long area of characters that
starts from capital d
followed by any other capital character
or any number
and step 3 find a source that sells
dogecoin
and voila buy dodge coins so that brings
us to what is dogecoin wallet
a dogecoin wallet is something where you
can stop store
receive or send dogecoins technically it
is very similar to a real live wallet
dogecoin wallet consists of its public
and private key
connecting it to the distributed ledger
over the dogecoin network
you can use your wallet's public key
which also functions as your coin
address
for your bank account number for
dogecoin where anyone can track the
transactions made
by maintaining the anonymity of the user
the private key of your wallet is used
to approve transactions
in the ledger your wallet's public key
is used to receive doj coins from other
users
on the other hand your wallet's private
key is only used to send torch points
to other users in the network so what
are the types of dogecoin wallet
doch coin wallet is of two types digital
dot coin wallet
and physical dodge point wallet digital
doj coin wallet
is accessible through the web and you
can also download it
according to your handset or operating
system
on the other hand physical dojo and
wallets are pretty expensive
and less accessible so moving on let's
see how to create a dogecoin wallet
to create a coin wallet for yourself you
will have to go through the following
steps
step one choose the correct wallet
dotecoin core wallet and multi-touch
wallet have been created
and are maintained by the developers
team of dogecoin
here we will be using the dogecoin core
wallet as reference
step 2 download and install the dogecoin
wallet
in your handset you can also use the
official website of this wallet
for your windows and step 3 open the
dogecoin wallet application
and verify your dogecoin wallet address
and that is it
it is this easy to create and have your
dogecoin wallet
now when you have your douche coin
wallet in your hand
let's see how you can use it on the very
bottom of the home page of your wallet
there are two options request coins
where you can request torch coins from
other users
in the dogecoin network and send coins
where you can send dogecoins to other
users in the dojo network
to receive coins first click on the
request coins button
second enter the required number of
coins you want to request
and third have the below generated
barcode scanned by the user
you wish to request the mount
now to send coins first type the
dogecoin wallet address to whom you want
to send dogecoins
enter the required amount you wish to
send to that user
and third click on send and there you go
now you can use your dogecoin wallet
whenever and wherever you want
this makes me wonder why is dogecoin so
popular
despite being in tough competition with
other strong cryptocurrencies
like bitcoin dogecoin has never missed
an opportunity to be in the limelight
dogecoin's popularity is mainly
attributed to its vast and dedicated
community
other than that social platforms like
reddit and twitter
also promoted dogecoin to a great extent
due to its fun factor
and the whole joke story behind it
celebrities
like snoop dogg kevin jonas elon musk
also started taking an interest in
dogepoint and posting pictures and
comments on their social media handles
which increased the craze of dogecoin
all around the world
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that
for free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
so this was all about dogecoin wallet
now let's have a look at the top 5
deutsche point wallets of 2021
these are the top five dogecoin wallets
of 2021.
ledger nano x trees model t kept key
binance and kraken kraken
is primarily a cryptocurrency exchange
platform
but can perfectly act as a dogecoin
wallet
all you need to do is to register and
then buy some dogecoins
it is a very secure and reliable
cryptocurrency exchange platform
it charges a very low fees for every
transaction taking place on it
and it accepts a pretty decent amount of
fiat money
now we have almost reached the end of
this video if i missed anything
important
do let me know in the comment section i
hope you enjoyed this video on document
wallet
and learn something new from it if you
like this video
then please do hit the like button and
thanks for watching this video and stay
tuned
for more updates and videos from simply
learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here